Supreme Court nominee Brett Cavanaugh is
now being accused of only hiring female
law clerks who look like models yeah
after hearing this Trump said I told you
the guy has great judgement that's my
kind of guy I like him
speaking of Trump president Trump
advised the Spanish government to build
a wall to block out migrants that's what
he that's we told the Spanish government
Trump told Spain trust me the last thing
you want coming into your country is a
bunch of spanish-speaking people I love
it when a crowd is quiet waits a second
[Applause]
it's the tie isn't it is it the time
that's how I got us off to a weird start
I'll get you back with this one
president Trump called the invasion of
Iraq the single greatest mistake in US
history
yeah response many Americans said well
second greatest
in her new book in your new book stormy
Daniels you've all heard about the
stormy Daniels book I'm sure yeah
and her new book stormy Daniels said
President Trump has a small penis I
never thought I'd say this but in
Trump's defense if you're a porn star
your frame of reference for penis size
might be a little off I'm just saying
poor guy only has ten inches a judge has
ruled that the State Department must
grant a passport to someone even if they
don't declare a gender yeah the judges
exact words were you can travel wherever
you want to Conan
[Applause]
you